I am Noah and I and boot camp this is
your 3 minute boot camp full body
workout full body unit small body I want
to really recruit everything from our
toenails to our hair follicles so we're
gonna go into a split lunge press
remember forms always first what you're
gonna want to do is just step into that
lunge remember to keep that knee right
over that heel step it back
knee right over that heel but if you can
get a little intense with it
intense moves I'm gonna burn a lot of
calories a lot quicker so after that
moving one minute on the move we're
gonna take it right down we're gonna
slow it up but we're gonna stick with
that full body we're gonna take into a
squat deep deep squat power out so I
want that explosivity drawing from your
core to really elevate these weights now
as opposed to pressing so you're cut
your arms are kind of just dead weight
it's not just coming from all I'm going
that way blender toes to your knees
your hips and your core that fires the
weights up then we're gonna bring it
down drop one weight right here one of
my favorite moves unilateral moves it
works the floor really well anytime work
in an imbalance scale so take it down
rodeo yep uppercut that way 30 seconds
each side okay and are you rolling yeah
bro bro every time so right here for you
back strong plank position draw it to
your hips talk about start it up and
we're gonna hit right to the next move
square those feet up hey toes point
right forward feet are about hip-width
apart
deep deep deep range of motion that
squat we got it right now start it up
let's go all that weights in those heels
bring those feet in a little closer deep
into that button I want you to get all
the way below that knee line that's
gonna engage the glutes and let's take
it to the last move minutes up we're
going right to the last move I'll take
one weight right here right hand row to
your hip jump it up power it up through
that core right there perfect that's a
perfect plank perfect plant your hips
aren't dipping you're keeping it strong
from the back of your head all the way
to your heels nice alignment perfect and
switch it up thirty Seconds let's hit it
thirty right there power through it
always be explosive on that press
contracting that core time brother I
know
to stay at this all day
so to recap this full-body bootcamp
workout we started off with a split
lunge press for minute tools then we
moved into squats overhead press at per
minute toll and then we went to the
unilateral jump back press and row
it's very compound movement very
difficult not scary difficult but it
will force you to work a lot of
stabilizer muscles and things like that
it's a great workout I like this one
thank you this big what I do is work out
you are a master sir thank you thank you
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes